hey Roger how's it going sue Aikens is
now the sole proprietor of kavik River
Camp I'm no longer somebody else's [ __ ]
I'm my own owner I run my own business
to make money she has to keep her runway
open during the busy summer months when
the camp serves as a remote outpost for
scientists hunters and bush pilots with
the new pressures of being owner sue has
brought on a helping hand to assist with
the drastically increased summer
workload and I brought him up here and
he wants to help out I just wanted to
tell you I appreciate you coming out I
love it up here I know we're both uh
we're not over the hill but but we're
looking at it from the summit not under
it he's a real good guy I mean he was 15
years
ANP mechanic a pilot and helicopter
mechanic and the Navy he's just got a
lot of hands-on experience and that's
something I need here your help is
pretty valuable you got a lot of talent
there I got a minion and I'm gonna use
them if I do something that bugs the
hell out of you the river is live in
that's above the baked holy
welcome to the saw Sue's camp sits in an
unpredictable floodplain since the flat
Tundra does little to hold the river at
bay during the runoff
unfortunately the runway is dangerously
close to flooding waters it is coming up
I see where it's coming up over the bank
area here yeah the water is stagnant
stationary here so it's obviously
waterlogged the ground the river is
coming up everything's melting you know
it's 24 hour daylight it's 50 degrees
right now it's gonna be 50 degrees until
the weather pattern changes there is no
sunset because it happens so late and so
much snow I mean you never get to know
exactly what
it's gone ahead BAM here it is sue we'll
have to keep our eye on the rising
waters but for now she has other
pressing matters blank kavik River Camp
is 60 miles away from one of Alaska's
most remote highways which ends in
Deadhorse I got two loads yesterday I
got three and four for today
boom boom boom I got to get going every
supply must be flown in by bush plane
yellow bubble
I've been up here a long time without
any help and I like it that way but does
Rick provide companionship absolutely
but for me the blessing is it's a very
finite limited engagement in the short
time it took to unload the plane over
two feet of water has made its way onto
the runway runway is how people get in
and out it's how supplies get in and out
it's how fuel gets in and out the runway
is life out here with this warm
temperature everything melts out so fast
the water table comes up and and you're
done